salut à tous ces pêcheurs de 13 ans
aujourd'hui avec alex et sa famille je
suis torse nu parce qu'un petit accident
vous allez voir plus tard je spoile donc
c'est parti pour la pêche on est sur le
spot deux criminels et de militaria
parce qu'on a déjà fait des munitions
des morceau d'obus donc tu es parti ça
va envoyer du lourd premier lancé on va
voir
au bon rien truc là j'ai quelque chose
avant au piquet de pénis à une balle
me
bell bell
allait venir faire leur mare et quand
même
clique et moi
tout de 4,4 angélique
comme 160 avaient décroché avec les plus
libres dans le sud de la france est
plutôt rare je sais que dans le nord il
en prend pas un trentaine alors
qu'est-ce qu'on a de beaux
morceaux de chair or le sueur ouais je
pense à suivre
c'est une belle bête le matelas autant
d'échos
une highway gens sympas
et ce morceau là j'ai déjà fait des
comme ça
c'est des bobines de cuivre ouais
non rasta
n'ont pas de poisson séché pour longer
c'est sympa ça ils en font plus des
comme ça trois tailles
un grelot
ouais
quant à bastos et gros lots de pêche
et encore la balle
deux grenades
ça ressemble un peu le goût d'une
grenade non
c'est son jeu préféré chercher la bouche
et et et on a dit non
on arrête
c'est là où est souvent la vase qui
t'attire aura une heureuse aux roses
blanches et luz
ah oui oui c'est ça elles sont vraiment
tout dans la vase au mieux la
à une seule balle et ça c'est un morceau
du clip ria et des bals dessus encore
elles sont défoncées c'est comme ça
alors essayez
trop loin ouais là non
ouais
au bas de tous ici il ya des ya des
restes de l'option way des munitions de
la gare la
merci
regard celle là elle est pété en deux
alors là j'ai chopé un truc au milieu il
vient petit à petit un kilo j'irai
stanley c'est une forme de moutons soit
toujours sympa ouais c'est ça calibre 50
ont largement
croise assez style et sa j'adore j'en
prenne sa suite à celle à l'épée qui
elle est payée mais c'est presque un
obus t'as vu le machin ouais c'est les
plus grosses bastos qui existent par
ailleurs y compris vraiment cher non
non
c'est pas assez 1 petit cent bah ouais
c'est qu'il est une pièce un centime
d'euro elle vient peut-être du
coffre-fort qui
même si c'est un cas de trop fort
peut-être moyen de désenvasement ces
grands
pense que c'est un morceau de motos fois
en vrai ça à leurs plans ça a l'air plus
lourd
ouais c'est pas un pouce c'est pas
impossible
à moins qu'un manteau de garde là tu le
sens
reims temps pardon wen en rasta dégage
dégage allez allez allez
salut
bientôt il ya le chien qui va y aller
idol aux
bordures en a très peu
dans l'eau quand même et la regarde là
les locaux
ont tenu la france quand même ouais
ouais je me suis pris un peu dans le jeu
nous ça va
ça fait du bien
ça pique
mais je me suis retrouvé à l'envers
quand même j'avais les jambes d'emprise
dans les herbes là
c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas avoir le
portable dans les poches
bon allez encore way
est
magnifique encore une grosse bastos
calibre 50 j'irai folie qui aurait la
taille de mon doigt a regardé un
nom c'est un type bien c'est bon c'est
bien c'est peut-être de la gare
aucune idée si vous savez en commentaire
est un morceau d'obus un prénom est le
problème ces deux ronds de rouzier a pas
d'amour cela
c'est rond ça fait comme celle et des
impacts de balles et il a même pas vu
donc là on va les voir sous pas si c'en
est un
j'espère pas propres seront par contre
dans sa voix à batterie périmètre
au courage
ace est profond la danse a fait canal
dans sept ans de la main sur tout le bas
du
corps un canal
instinct
ouais du coup une nouvelle munition
encore on compare les tailles mais avec
son perroquet les plus courtes mais plus
là
a
encore des balles au coco est ce que ce
ne serait pas une boucle de ceinture ça
on dirait bien ça c'est largement
possible et du coût de la guerre ou pas
forcément de ceinture mais une boucle ou
quoi sympa et deux balles de 4 98 encore
donc là on doit être à 100 munitions à
peu près on comptera ça tout à la fin
sympa voilà le résultat donc 97 balle ça
fait extrêmement plaisir d'avoir enfin
trouvé du militaria dédicace à alain
ciment et tous ceux qui en attendait
après il ya d'autres munitions du 6 mm
une pile pour la dépollution pour cette
voiture donc c'était une belle pêche
encore alors des mois saints si ça c'est
pas une bonne pêche n'est de retour pour
aller chercher ce qu'on avait laissé la
précédente avec alex donc cette fois ya
bâtisse qui nous rejoint on va plonger
wouah projet direct donc ça va il fait
20 degrés quand même dur mais un peu de
vent un peu il fait bientôt nuit
le compte est
bon
alors
le sens bien mais
doit à l'état joue
bouge pas
[Musique]
vraiment
le poids
voilà pour le pour le cnoa c'est un très
bon pneu je l'avais pas identiques c'est
un absent c'est un sujet
aux
jeux les films et
je t'ai finira pas
un peu risqué au
pistolet
trop énorme
poursuit
ça envoie du lourd
ce qui tient encore ouais